ninety-seven percent conviction rate
impressive and I just don't like to lose
you see private sector job you soon will
be court sided Laker games welcome back
to a segment that I used to do that has
been long dead and buried and I just
wanted to bring it back because I really
missed this segment it was a cool way
for me to be able to bring to light
movies that I felt were very good that
were generally overlooked perhaps didn't
make that much money at the box office
or critics didn't like it or people
don't like it or no one really knows
about it there are a lot of good movies
out there and a lot of times people like
to talk about the big ones and they sort
of tend to just overlook these little
ones that are actually very good gems
and just because people don't talk about
it doesn't mean they're not good so
today we're going to be talking about
the movie fracture stars Ryan Katherine
Redmond wants to violate you Gosling and
Anthony his stare can melt the polar ice
caps Hopkins the first ten minutes of
this movie set up the story so well it's
actually so involving the way this movie
opens
it shows Anthony Hopkins walking around
spying on his wife he sees that she is
having an affair with another man and he
plans her murder just meticulously you
see him murder her you see everything
that happens you see the cops come to
him you see him confess to it right in
front of the cops you see all that
within the first 10 minutes of this
movie this movie opens with such a great
bang that you wonder how in the world is
gonna get any better where else is it
gonna go he confesses directly to the
police officer who is there but guess
what that police officer yeah that's the
guy who's sleeping with his wife
enter Ryan Gosling he is a young fresh
lawyer he's just about to get out of
this firm he's been working for up to
the next level which is this huge firm
that wants him he's just a hot shark he
is the guy that everyone wants to work
for them for his last case at this
company he decides to take Anthony
Hopkins and figure out what he can do
because you know it's a side confession
blah blah blah it's over little does he
know that Anthony Hopkins is a very
clever man you don't mess with Anthony
Hopkins no you don't mess with him we
know that Anthony Hopkins killed his
wife we see in the opening scene but
he's able to find all these ways around
the law to be able to get out of his
problem and gosselin can do nothing
about it and all he wanted to do was get
out of that company but he decided to
take this one last case and so this film
is just filled with drama and it
so expertly acted Gosling puts on this
kind of southern accent this movie and
at first I was like how is this gonna
work and then as I got into the film and
as it continued I completely bought it
he was so good in this movie Hopkins is
always good and here he has this kind of
comical wit to him in the fact that he
knows that he is ruining goslings life
he's finding all these little loopholes
in the law to be able to escape through
goslings attacks as a lawyer the scenes
where these two characters faceoff
cinematic gold I go in there with a side
confession and I put this guy in jail
all right
I'm from the district attorney's office
you look closely enough you find
everything as a big spot where it can
break so later you look at come on I've
already found yours yeah this movie is
really stylish Lee directed as well
there's a great feel to the film it
isn't just a standard looking movie the
director definitely has an idea of what
he wants to do with the film and he's
able to make his scenes seem a little
bit different he really has a good
notion of lighting also in this movie
and the blu-ray which I bought recently
looks fantastic from beginning to end I
was totally engrossed in this movie and
without spoiling anything I will say the
finale of this film completely 100%
satisfying it was so great such an
interesting and intriguing and just mm
fracture he had not seen fracture I
implore you to I'm gonna give the film
an a-minus I think it's a great great
movie if you haven't seen it please
check it out it's on blu-ray DVD
everywhere just go see it it's a great
film especially if you're a fan of
Gosling or Hopkins I'm gonna try to do
more overlooked reviews from time to
time hopefully like once a month so if
you haven't seen fracture please check
it out until next time guys if you'd
like this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stubborn eyes